joining me here on the rich eisen show
via zoom
fresh off of 253 rushing yards
the all-time record in the history of
the indianapolis colts
getting set for his first playoff game
as such
he is jonathan taylor how are you
jonathan
i'm doing well i mean shoot we're we're
in the playoffs i mean that that's where
you want to be during this time of year
so it
it's an awesome feeling well you know
what um there is an eye on snickers and
you are wearing
you know the uh the the medallion for
the the hungriest player of the week so
congratulations on that
and we will get to that in a second but
i just want to read off some of the
accomplishments here if you don't mind
the 253 yards
uh that you galloped for beating out
hall of famer edrin james
for the most in the history of the colts
you joined edrin
and marshall faulk he's also in the hall
of fame as the only rookie running backs
in the history of the franchise
to run for over a thousand yards and
also have 10 or more touchdowns in a
season when you hear this
what what what goes through your mind
jonathan
it's it's just amazing it's humbling
really
when you mention the company that
i had the opportunity to put myself
around this past
week it kind of makes you want to work
harder because
you understand that you worked hard to
get to this point and it wasn't just
given to you so
it kind of makes you want to continue to
work because it's only right
by those guys because you know they put
in a ton of work to get there
and it would be a disservice of myself
to to try and stop working
uh just because you had a good game um
so it's just
it's amazing and humbling well i want to
describe for the radio audience you just
put good game in air quotes
you can remove the air quotes jonathan
that was that was in that was a good
game you had one
your 45 yarder to kind of salt it away
is something your team needed
your team needed it wasn't uh wasn't
coming very easy against a one-win team
in
in jacksonville and i'm wondering what
that means
you know what feeling that gives you
that you salted
it away for your entire team the it
being a playoff spot
for you it means a lot um that's what
you you play the game
in order to earn the trust of your
coaches and teammates
and that i'm the kind of guy to where i
want to know
that my teammates and my coaches can
trust me you know kind of when the game
is on the line you know to call my
number
and understand that i'll be able to get
my job done and do it at a high level
and so the 253 yards by
you in this game following up uh
a performance um prior to the week
against pittsburgh where you had two
rushing touchdowns you've got seven
touchdowns in the last
four weeks including 150 yards against
vegas in a in a big game
what what has happened for you in the
last month normally this is where
rookie wall hits and you seem to have
absolutely destroyed that if it actually
exists
for you i think it was really leaning on
my teammates especially in the running
back room uh
nahin jordan marlin being able to lean
on those guys
you know there were a lot of times when
adversity hit throughout this season
and one of the biggest things that they
told me was that
you know adversity is to be expected if
you came into this league thinking that
you was not going to face adversity
this is not the right you know league
for you and i think
understanding that process and
understanding that i know adversity is
going to hit
stick to the process stay patient
because
that's going to allow you to persevere
and push through is what helped me
kind of continue to get better each and
every single week
yeah in the middle of the season you had
i guess what would be somewhat of a
a dip you know where you weren't near
you're
you're not nearly on the field as much
not nearly getting as many touches was
there something in the middle of the
season for you
that required you to have a step back
taken by you
or your coaching staff doing that on
your behalf was there something like
that
yeah and definitely it was definitely a
mindset change as well
understanding you know in college you
know you're kind of
used to being on the field a ton
and coming into this league you have
a lot of elite talent around you
so understanding that you don't
necessarily you don't need to have
the ball or plays called around you 100
of the time because
you have guys and men who are more than
capable of playing an elite high level
but what matters is when your number is
called will you be ready
to play at a high level make the most
out of that opportunity so once
you know you had i had that mindset
change of understanding that no matter
when or how my number is called
be able to do my job at a high level no
matter if it's
with the ball without it do it at a high
level so that
coaches and teammates are able to see
hey jonathan
is playing really well either when he
has the ball or when he doesn't
and that's how you're in the trust of
your coach's teammate i'm i'm jonathan
taylor of the colts here on the rich
editor this is fascinating to me because
i never
you know having watched you in the big
ten and watched you you know destroy my
alma mater
um you know in michigan as i've i've
watched you in games that mean a lot to
me personally and then
i've watched you in games because i'm a
big ten uh
fan i never thought you jonathan taylor
would need to have some sort of reset or
lesson about what to do in the balls in
your hand
or or have some sort of proper mentality
when that happens so
what are you referring to when you're
saying this about your journey and
getting to
the point where you're ready for the
playoffs at the top of your game right
now well i i wonder what you're
referring to right there
yeah so a lot of times people will
really
make it down in the slumps let's say you
know they they had a bad game and
they're not sure like man am i really
cut out for this and i think one of the
biggest things
is realizing that hey adversity is going
to come you're here for a reason i mean
that's one of the biggest things that i
got from my teammates is
you're fine i mean it's just your rookie
year you're here for a reason
you need some time to adjust i mean it's
been a crazy year but
stick with your process you know don't
waver or change from
the process that you've gone through
that got you to where you're at uh here
you know
if you're gonna have a bad game
adversity is gonna happen only
you can do is to continue to prepare and
try to minimize
minimize the amount of negative plays or
the mistakes you might have
and continue to push through because
like all in all the biggest message that
i got from my teammates was
you're here for a reason so keep that in
the back of your mind
did you have a welcome to the nfl moment
early on in the season somebody hit you
some sort of moment where you thought
okay that hole that normally looks like
you'd be able to gallop through it
uh in wisconsin closed up something like
that do you have any
moments like that jonathan but that
definitely did happen
one instance happened uh when
i was we were playing the texans we were
playing the texans and of course you
watch film on
you know how guys blitz all the time so
you're like okay this guy is a thumper
or this guy likes to run around
uh but but this time then this just
shows you
this kind of opened my eyes to you know
how elite
the nfl is um this this guy
we were playing on the texans it was
cunningham and
on film you know you know he comes down
he plays hard so you kind of get ready
you know you got to get ready if he's
coming down the pipe i mean you gotta
you gotta man up
um and then on one play he kind of hit a
heavy just a little bit
to make me think oh he might he might be
dropping or he might not be coming and
then he hit the gas he hit the gas pedal
uh he kind of ran right through me uh
and that that's not a good feeling uh
when you get ran through on the field
and so that's one of those moments like
okay that did that didn't happen in the
big ten that that that's now you're in
the big time
pretty much that didn't happen the big
ten which is all on film is what you got
and you understood and you knew
everything uh but it just goes to show
you that
guys understand what they put on film in
the league and they understand what they
need to do to keep
you know defenders or in my case uh you
know
the offense on their toes what was it uh
i guess again i know your your rivals in
the league and you're trying to compete
with him in the league with j.j watt um
seeing him twice i mean mr wisconsin
badger as well did you guys have sort of
uh
a moment the first time most definitely
uh and that was it was something that
was a real big
moment for me being an nfl understanding
that
i mean he was a legend at the the
university of wisconsin and he's a
legend and then i felt and being able to
compete against him
was something that i will never take for
granted because
one badge of pride so i can say hey you
know i got to compete against one of the
best
in college football one of the best in
nfl jj y um but just uh the amount of
a class that he has and how he goes
about his business
you know in between plays it's you know
coming for you jt you know jokes
and then when the play is about to go
it's all business it's all business with
him so that was a really really fun
moment
i'm sure a few minutes left here with
jonathan taylor who got the the
medallion for snickers hungriest player
of the week for the final week of the
season
um and obviously you know you're you're
a team player you've mentioned team many
many different times but the guy who's
handing you the ball
is a pretty special player with
potentially this being his last window
of opportunity to get that ring i'm
wondering
how much that might be on your mind as
the rest of your teammates as you head
off
to buffalo this week with philip rivers
as your quarterback
jonathan i mean when you mention philip
rivers you kind of say it all
i mean 17th year there's not
actually no there's not one look he
hasn't seen in nfl
um so we put our trust completely in
philips hands we know he's going to get
us
in the right position for success so
that makes us go
even harder because we understand that
he is going to
bust his tail to make sure that each
play call he has
each check that he has is setting us up
for success only thing we have to do
is execute at a high level um and it's
an honor and blessing to say hey
like i got to protect i've got to play
with philip rivers he's a he's a future
hall of famer he's a legend
and that's something that no one can
take away from me and it's going to be a
story that i had to tell for a long long
time
first time you he throws you past though
when he when he does that sort of you
know he rests the ball in his hand and
like he basically said he told me once
he did that as a kid because he needed
to
get it around guys who were a little bit
taller or he knew that that's the way he
needed to throw a ball was it
weird for you to see the ball come out
that way from your quarterback
that was a bit of surprise uh when you
know you first started catching passes
with phillip
uh and that's it takes repetition i will
tell you that it takes a little bit of
repetition to get used to
and once you get into the groove and
then you go and catch passes from
another quarterback
that seems weird because you're so used
to catching passes from philip
uh but no that's what makes him so
unique and he's been able to play at a
high level for many years uh
you know with his play style and now
here comes your first playoff game
jonathan
and you're going to buffalo and people
in western new york
you're from the new jersey area so
you're you're somewhat familiar with
you know the football scene in in in
western new york uh
being in that you know that that that
area knowing that buffalo has been a
long time for them
uh fans are going to be in the building
for the first time all season long
uh the defense will be hyped josh allen
is like kind of like the mandalorian at
quarterback
you know and he's this is a challenge
for you
uh and you're gonna be relied on here
i'm wondering how you're preparing
yourself
knowing that you've adjusted so far and
you've gotten to this point with all
these adjustments and
another one is probably going to be
required that you're not
personally familiar with just yet i'm
wondering how you're approaching this
right now so one thing i think that's
really cool
is coach wright he talked about it today
is the best way to handle a big game
is the bigger the game the smaller your
world so a lot of times when you get big
games people think oh
i need to have a 40-yard touchdown run i
need to
you know catch a one-handed interception
when really
it's i'm going to make sure i have the
right reads every time
i'm going to make sure that i run with
low pad level or if you're on defense
i'm going to make sure that
you know i'm in my back pedal make sure
i go through my reads
so i think that's a really cool approach
and that's how we've been taking their
approach each
each week um these past few weeks is
just make our world really small we know
these games are big
to everyone on the outside but if we
make our world small and focus on
the little things we need to do the game
won't seem bigger than what it is
spoken like a guy who's come back from
down 30 points in the stadium you're
going to play
in a playoff game you know you're aware
that your coach is authored one of the
greatest comebacks in the history i mean
you you might you usually the buffalo
fans don't really
welcome in the guests but they they
might bow down before your bus as it's
pulling into the stadium
that was coach mike actually told us
that story uh
and it was it was just awesome to to see
how
his journey was and that you have to be
ready at all times
you never know when the play is going to
be to play you never know when your time
is coming so play every play like it's
your last
when did he tell you the story under
just this week did he tell you or
previously
it was it was earlier on in the season
uh and it was really just a message of
you know make sure you know stay ready
so you don't have to get ready
everyone matters every little role on
this team whether it's players coaches
uh staff you all matter you all
contribute towards each and every single
win each week all right
well look man uh let's get to the bling
before we let you go
let me see it hold it up i'll try and
describe it it says hungry there it is
okay how is that important it looks
losing on zoom right here
can you see that is it shining through
the zoom it does wait a minute
if i had shades in my office i'd put
them on right now
this is this is amazing i mean i'm just
snickers hungriest player of the week is
it's a huge honor i mean to come
in the last week of the regular season i
mean it's it's huge uh shout out to ben
baller
i mean this is i don't even know how he
even thought or came up with this this
is a dope design
and people will be able to check this
out on my social media
uh and i still i'm still in disbelief
every time i look at it i'm like man
jonathan you're snickers hungriest
player of the week
wrap my head around it everything's been
moving so fast this week i mean we're in
the playoffs we're trying to get ready
snickers hunger's player of the week but
i mean it's just
it's an honor i mean you look at the
guys who won it throughout this season i
mean and they're
ballers like a true baller so it's it's
a pleasure and an honor
and then ben baller got that thing
around you know he's designed that thing
around your neck and
pretty sweet stuff jonathan i know we
spoke at the outset of the season you
said you had goals and i'm assuming
making the playoffs with one of them so
congratulations on that
1000 yard season first time in the
league congrats on that
you put your name next to edrin james
and marshall faulk for crying out loud
which is amazing for your
organization and your career and uh
you're good people thanks for the time
and good luck in the playoffs let's chat
soon
thank you so much rich i appreciate you
having me on again shout out to ben
baller and snickers for making me
snickers hunger's player of the week you
got it and your social media where
people can see it let's get that
let's get that out there what is what is
it there for you everybody can check out
my social media
at jt23 and you'll be able to see me
with the snickers hunters player of the
week fantastic good luck in buffalo
let's chat soon
thank you so much that's jonathan taylor
on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here